it does not feel like it's been 10 years
Andy Cohen celebrates the 10-year
anniversary of watch what happens live
the host was joined by LuAnn de Lesseps
Chrissy Teigen and John Mayer to
celebrate the milestone I fan out on you
for a minute you wrote one of the
funniest things I've ever read
I gotta tell you somebody tweeted you a
photo of a mummified person looking as
if they were pleasuring themselves and
you wrote a simple caption on top hell
yeah
Chrissy tweets into the show she texts
me personally there is no form of
communication in which she does not
reach out to both the show to Bravo to
the housewives and myself
John was in town he's in town on tour
with the Grateful Dead and he said you
want to get dinner on Monday night I
said it's my 10th anniversary show I
said he said is there anything I can do
I go yeah come on and countess LuAnn
performed on a runway full of drag
queens
[Music]
I love being on stage so I you know
there's always a little nerves but it's
it was really a lot of fun ET spoke with
andy exclusively on set after the taping
it feels like it's been the longest and
best hangover you can imagine I would
say Oprah's my favorite cast of all time
who do I still want to get on Michelle
Obama
Madonna Diana Ross the list is long
[Music]